[Applaudissements]
tu as mis mon cœur en
bouteille mon voilier ne voguera
plus Marius a regagné
Marseille Fanny l'a
eu le long des qua mon n
clapote l'aventure est en
dimanché entre la Nice et la
belelote tu
as
gagneré c'est une histoire Bale en
somme la vie d'une femme et d'un
homme une vie qui a plus que de la
mémoire qui a pas d'avenir et pas
d'histoire une vie basse
calories vie sans vie sans pain sans sel
sans moi sans
[Musique]
Elle à table les enfants à
table les géranium sur le
balcon le petit potage minable
une vie
con je drive vers la
retraite que je prendrai à 60 ans au
bout d'une existence
honnête
papa
maman c'est une histoire banale en
somme j'attends plus devant le
téléphone je frmis plus quand j'entends
t
pas je me sens tout seul mais je
t'attends
pas une vivace
calorie une vie sans vie sans vin sans
sucre sans joie sans
[Musique]
lucre dans
l'armoire la vieille
voche celle qui a usé son dos dans des
quartiers plus ou moins
Moch dans
desist maintenant felour moqu tcouleur
et
grandutand hier
encoreête
à
Colombo c'est une histoire banale en
somme on vit toute l'année en
automne plus d'avanture quand tu te met
nu ton corps est Mvé je le vois plus les
jeux sont il y a eu mal d'onne il y a
plus personne ni dans mon lit ni dans ma
vie
on est séparé sans le savoir on fait
cœur à
[Musique]
peur